what's going on everybody and welcome to
part three of our data visualization
application development tutorial with
python and - in this tutorial what we're
be doing is building on the last
tutorial where we basically made an
interactive UI that accepted some text
input output that exact text input and
then later we accepted some input and
tried to output that input ^ - but you
can get much more you can get much more
advanced than just that and that's kind
of what I want to exemplify here so to
begin I'm going to be using pandas and
pandas data reader if you don't have
them you can do a pip install upgrade
pandas and pandas data reader in the
future the methodology that I use here
could very well change if it does check
out the text-based version of this
tutorial and/or make complaints in the
comment section if there's no updates in
the text-based version and we'll do my
best to find it an upgrade old source
maybe I'll use something like quando or
something like that but basically the
objective here for me is to show you
that you can create like an input field
and then graph based on whatever you
type in that input field so you can
graph any sort of symbol like Quan doll
has all kinds of things that you could
you could chart from housing markets to
finance to agriculture stud to
everything leaves just so many data sets
so anyways this is just an example like
I said before I feel like every time I
do something finance related people tell
me they don't know and understand
finance and they hate it that's totally
fine just ignore the fact this is
finance it's just data organized by date
okay
that's it so so with that let's get into
it so what we're gonna do is we're going
to use the pandas data reader to pull in
some stock information based on whatever
ticker we want to pass so I think what
I'm going to do here is kind of my
objective here is to show you kind of in
a much more higher level kind of way how
you could piece together an app like
this and how truly simple it is and I
feel like if I type everything line by
line
it's kind of pointless so I'm just going
to kind of show you and if you want you
can go to the text-based version of this
tutorial and copy and paste along with
me or you can write it out if you want
but anyways this is how to use the the
actual data reader you just all you're
really doing is you're specifying
starting time and ending time and then
you're gonna read that stuff into a data
frame if you don't know what data frames
are and you want to learn basically the
rules the lowdown and skinny of what a
data frame is is it's basically like
Excel for Python it's just columns and
rows but you can do like a lot of
operations stuff like that so it's kind
of like Excel for Python but if you want
to learn more you can go to Python
program in it go to data analysis and I
have a whole series on doing data
analysis with pandas anyway with that
let's go ahead and run this real quick
just so you can kind of see what's going
on here so you'll get this warning or at
least you might and then eventually it
was just might not work and that's why I
made that caveat in the beginning but at
the end of the day hopefully you'll get
some data that's like this it's indexed
by date you've got open high low close
volume and again if you don't know what
that means just some values so close out
of this and so so that's how we can grab
that data but let's say we want to
actually graph that data in in - well
how might we actually go about doing
that so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
leave this here and I'm just gonna move
this over I'm gonna come into here now
and I'm gonna just copy and paste over
some code that we used in the beginning
so this is the code from part one of our
tutorials so if you recall it just gave
a simple graph hopefully if I save this
I won't have server issue let's see what
happens dang it oh it didn't restart you
know okay hold on everybody just wait
hold on let's see if I can get it
otherwise I'm gonna have to open up the
old the old task manager okay let me
pause okay I really thought I had
outsmarted it but I guess I didn't so
let's try again okay
start that server and come back over
here that's refresh okay now we have our
basic app and hopefully all the changes
I make from here the what I tried to do
is save this under a different name
thinking that would circumvent all these
problems but it didn't so bummer
anyway so now what we want to do is
rather than making this graph let's
graph the the pandas graph instead so so
basically what we're going to do is we
need to bring in those imports from
pandas 4 so the data reader and the date
time so so if I just come over here like
this is the script that we were using I
basically like I'm gonna need all this
information here so if I came down here
pasted that in let's make the end time I
think you give you date time date time
dot now so let's just do whatever the
time is right now for you you lovely
folks then we can bring in the actual
stock info so I'm just gonna say let's
just say stock equals TSLA for Tesla and
and then what we'll say is we'll bring
over here we go DF and then rather than
Tesla there we'll just throw it in there
ok now inside of this graph layout the
ID we still keep that example graph the
title should now be let's just make the
title stock and then let's get rid of
one of these X and Y's we're going to
leave the line version and then rather
than being the SF example we can bring
in a Tesla or rather stock and then
let's bring in
rather so the X and the y this should be
DF index and then this will be DF and
we'll just do dot close so DF dot
capital C close once we've done that
still line still stocks I think we're
gonna need hello - I don't need this
either we really could just do oh my god
finance okay
hopefully that updates let's see it says
it's restarted let's see if the - gods
approve and they do whoa okay so it was
that simple to bring in the graph into -
now how much more challenging might it
be for us to - instead bring in have
this live like let the user type in the
actual ticker rather than hard coding it
in the script so now what we're going to
do is bebop on back over to our script
arena here and what are the things that
we have to change well the graph itself
probably should maintain well we don't
have to have a default I mean so so
basically what we'd want to do is have
like so as you'll see here what is the
app dot layout well all the app dot
layout really is it's a div tag that
contains a graph so rather than
interactively returning some text what
if we interactively just return the
graph element from that - core
components right can we actually do that
spoiler alert you've actually already
seen it so you already know the answer
is and yes we can
so now what we're gonna do instead is
let's get rid of this here and I think
what we'll do is rather than this let's
just call this symbol to graph and then
rather than necessarily this being a
graph let me make sure it should be this
I'm just going to confirm that
yes so we'll start with that that div
element there of what symbol do we want
to graph now what we want is an input
field like we had before that'll be an
ID we're gonna call this input value
let's leave value blank that way your
scheme seems kind of silly to have that
pre-populated then every time you delete
it's gonna like rerun we just want to do
that so leave value empty and then we're
gonna say type equals text okay so now
let me make some space I always like it
when it's up here okay so type equals
text okay so that's our input now what
you're gonna want to have is somewhere
to stuff the output so we're gonna do
that and in HTML div so a div tag ID
will be output - graph cool so now what
we have to do is like we had before we
need that callback so we're gonna make
app dock callback and again it'll just
be a nice little wrapper that contains
output from this time the oh we didn't
import them it was - dot dependencies so
from - dot depend and sees we're gonna
import input my output leaves no typos
that will cause too much of a headache
the pendant sees it looks like I spelled
it right okay back to work output okay
so inside of output we're gonna say the
component underscore ID is we want to
output to the output graph the component
property will be the contents basically
so we're just gonna call that children
so that's the output now again the input
maybe someone can answer this actually
no no for sure
why does input need to be a list does it
even need to be a list don't really want
to test it live
due to the annoying server issues if you
hit a bug so I'd rather not but I'm
curious actually to be honest component
ID you
equals input and then the components
property that is of interest to us is
whatever the value of that form is so
okay and for stylistic sake we'll add
that on a new line okay now we want to
actually make that graph so define
update will call this update graph we'll
call it input data and now let's see if
we're okay so now what we can do do we
have date time and all that we did bring
that and cool so now we want to do is
we're just going to do it delete I did I
guess we deleted that graph I'm gonna
copy and paste our graph over just to
save time there's no reason for us to be
doing that we shouldn't have I should
have left it open in like another window
or something so you guys would have to
anyways
shows going to continue on starting in
and again that should be end dot now and
that was trying to sneak it's 1:00 and
rather than Tesla it should be input
data and just for clarity this is the
ticker we want to pull this is the
source from which we want to pull it and
then start time end time okay so that's
going to dynamically pull the data frame
now all we knew need to do is graph it
and because I've already shown you this
the code to graph it just for the sake
of doing it the the code to graph it was
with DCC so is this DCC graph and then
all this stuff you've seen it before
rather than graphing it all you really
need to do is return it because it's
going to be a part of that it's just
gonna be a child of that div right here
okay I believe we're ready let's check
it out
let's see if when I save this if we err
out a hidden err okay so let's run it
more time see invalid syntax
what do we close at all we closed it off
why didn't somebody tell me now we're
screwed
damn I don't want to do this again okay
I'm gonna have to probably restart a
server but it's gonna be okay everybody
it's gonna be okay let's see let me just
see let me just see we can hope and pray
oh oh oh
are the gods favoring us today they
might be nice
okay the app actually works and we
didn't have to restart the server thank
the Lord
okay okay so that's a slightly more
complex example so going from just three
outputting the same text that we've
input to running a really simple
function on that input to now you know
generating an entire graph based on that
input and even then really much the code
it's this stupid graph code but yeah so
so pretty cool how simple this really
all this stuff really is I mean to do
this in like flask plus even if you were
using plotly or bouquet or whatever you
might be using gosh it would be a pain
it just really be a pain and to make it
update live like that you'd have to know
so many like different loop things and
it would take a while whereas this is
just so sample like you just uh I really
like - I'm really impressed the server
thing is annoying but the ease with
which you can make these apps is just
crazy and it's almost like like honestly
it's tempting to use - to do a lot of
stuff that isn't even graph related I
just haven't seen a framework like I
wish I wish I could do this sort of
thing and maybe you can with like giant
like I would expect Django to be able to
do like live updating stuff would like
react and stuff this simply but to my
knowledge it doesn't at least come out
of the box doing that but so and correct
me or someone tell me if there exists a
web framework for Python that is this
absolutely lovely to use
because I really like this and maybe
that's just because I've tried to create
so many so many of these like you eyes
that happen to use graphs for like data
analysis and stuff anyways won't waste
any more of your time
pretty cool and so now what we're going
to do is move on so at this point it's
what we've covered is you know how to
make you know basically how to have a
user's interactivity updated graph one
of the other really common things to do
is to just have a graph automatically
update itself so in the next tutorial
what I'm going to do is show how we can
create live updating graphs that just
update based on like an interval kind of
like the the matplotlib graphs and stuff
and pretty much everything is going to
update based on an interval usually it's
a little more challenging to update
based on and like a like a database
update or something like that but as you
could imagine it actually wouldn't be
the end of the world to do that via -
but anyways we're just gonna update via
interval so that's what we're gonna do
in the next tutorial if you have
questions comments concerns suggestions
whatever feel free to leave them below
also feel free to join our discord link
in the description otherwise I'll see
you in the next tutorial